[Müzik]
nasıl bu hale geldik bu hallere gelmek
için neler geçirdik hep kafada dönen
sorular bunlar
evrimleşmeden önce nasıl bir görünümlü
olduğumuzu kimse bilemez fakat az çok
tahmin edilebilir
iyor bundan yaklaşık 50.000 yıl önce
dünyada 6 çeşit
işin daha da enteresan tarafı ise
gücenslerden sadece bir tanesini hala
hayat
ının
sen ben o hepimiz birer
yani belirttiğimiz ırk kavramının
Aslında daha yakın içer
bir şey Hepimiz aynıyız Hepimizin bir
beyni bir kalbi Diken
Bizi Birbirimizden ayırabilecek tek şey
düşün
ecek düşünceler çevreye göre şekillenir
Üzüm üzüme baka baka kararır derler ya
aynen öyle işte bu yüzden ilişki
kurduğumuz İnsanlara çok
dikkat et bizde negatifte etkili
bazı ilişkiler başta bize doğru gelse de
üstü örtülmüş bir çukurdur aslında
Bu insanlarla ilişkiye devam etmemiz
bize başta hoş gelebilir fakat sonradan
bize zarar verecektir fakat hayata bir
kere geliyoruz denemesek de olmaz ki
lazım acı Sevgi Sevinç Mutluluk üzüntü
bunları yaşamadan Yani deneyimlemeden
nasıl ders alacağız ki
tam olarak bu yüzden
bana zarar vermeyecek gerek Bilici olsun
gerek sıkıcı her şeyi deneyimlemek benim
hayatımın kuralıdır
spontane olmak Bence yapılabilecek en
eğlenceli şeylerden biridir
pantolonun olduğu sürece bir heyecan var
aşk ve Sport emri mesela karşımıza hiç
beklemediğiniz bir zamanları çıkar
insan tarihinde psikoloji en önemli
etkenlerdendir her şeyi o anki
psikolojimi düşünceler belir
ler bombanın kaçıncı senede patladı
[Müzik]
hepsini o an yetkili olan kişinin
düşünceleri belirler
herkesin de düşünceleri farklı
olduğundan geçmişe bakarken Empati
yapmak çok da doğru değil
di empati yapılması için o olayın
gündeme yakın modellikte gerçekleşmiş
olması gerekir Buna bir de şu yönden
bakalım Biz şu an tek cinsin insanlar
olarak kendi içimizde empati kuramıyorsa
Ve tabii ki kimse bildiğini Düşünmek
zorunda değil fakat
dünyadaki 7 milyar insan popülasyonu
birbirini düşünemiyorsa bunun 6 katının
bizi nerelere sürükleyebileceğine aklına
bile getiremiyorum şunu bile düşünmek
lazım O insanlar bizim gibi mi
düşünüyordu o insanlar bizim gibi mi
iletişime geçiyordu
geçmişe bakarken Empati yapmak
çok da gelmiyor
bir yönden bakalım düşüncenin
ve hatırlarını kullanarak hareket
edilirse çok da işe yarayabilir
denemek lazım Bu yüzden deneme
[Müzik]
her şey denemeye dayalı
deneme yanılma kavramı insanın
gelişiminde çok büyük katkı sağladı
bizi buraya ne getirdiyse deneme yanılma
oldu zaten mesela ateşli su birleşik
ateşle kum birleştirilmesi Can bulunur
muydu
Bizler şu an dünyadaki en zeki
canlılarız benim asıl merak ettiğim soru
şu Biz diğer canlılardan daha zeki
olmamıza rağmen diğer canlıların neden
daha hızlı ve pratik çözümler buluyor
mesela
bazen daha zeki olmak pratik çözümlerden
kaçmamıza sebep olabilir her şeyi çok
düşünmek bazı şeyleri Gözden kaçırmamıza
neden olabilir
Zeki insanların
çok fena sosyaldir o kadar çok düşünecek
şeyleri vardır ki size zaman ayıramazlar
Halbuki biraz çeşitli
insanlık geçirir
belki görüşü bir
evde öyle yemekte Bazı şeylerde çok
işimize yarayabilecekken Bazı şeylerde
bize çok şey kaybettirebilir
Örneğin ailesinden aldığı bilgiye göre
yabancıdan dondurma olmayan bir çocuk
hayatını kurtarmışken görünüşünden
dolayı yaklaşmadığımız insanlar Aslında
kafa dengeniz olabilir denemek lazım bu
yüzden
denemeyen insan Bence zaten cehenni
hayatımıza cevapsız sorulara ve olumsuz
düşüncelerle doldurmayalım deneyelim
[Alkış]